yo and welcome to this video the
marzipan cat and I've got black what
kind of offbeat stuff can i play let's
go with the names of each defense yeah
that is mostly transposing to other
stuff there's f5 which is completely
crazy maybe this this thing here let
that certainly play a playable option
like g6 going to some kind of port
defense or Bishop chief form should you
fall maybe maybe d5 as possible here d 5
95 95 no it's not happening ok so maybe
five now then yeah that's really
completely completely out of my usual
out of my usual routine here may be here
Bishop e7 at least its kind of closed so
i'm not getting wiped out quickly i
would like to get this dark squared
bishop traded some how to share p7 move
a six and then up to G fire I am okay so
he wants to prevent that
talk about a slow development maybe a
six or spawn cousin after age 5f to go
back to be seven that seems very very
backwards laughs okay how do I play here
Bishop to b5 is irritating me quite a
bit and do that ma I know it's even
slower okay so okay here at least it
looks like i'm looking at g5
so we will go for f1 yeah my night only
seven that's it's a real debris problem
if I would somehow managed to care to
get this you know it it looks terrible
but okay yeah yeah yeah but should be 75
is my idea the movie 5 here now is the
problem that that could possibly just
wipe me out
I hope that works otherwise I'm just
toast here ed6 quindi 6 that is my idea
the cross pin and that's really walking
on the razor's edge this kind of this
kind of opening here where it's not
really the the first moves I head up
later this age 6 and so on that was
probably really a bit much the movie 6
is also very nice actually for what okay
didn't happen chicks here and then he
takes g5
hmm
Tiki five push-ups 595 check on e5 king
of aid for can you survive that it's
very difficult probably check the move
d6 looks very strong
and the six-strong for chica drug cheeks
Queenie Selma is that survivable I
probably have to take I don't don't see
it different or something else
maybe 96 actually yeah I let's see Queen
to e7 I don't think I can I don't see
how I can to keep p7 here let's do that
Queen takes King cakes night p 79 f 6
might still be a fight trying to get g
form yeah but it's really not enough ok
it doesn't want to trade I understand
them with this King you don't want to
trade I still thought I still think it
was was a good good endgame but I really
understand probably i would have also
prefer to keep things on the board but
i'm not sure about the objective merit
them anyway to get the Queen traded not
really
i 95 now my dad five is just good maybe
maybe I can survive King 28 somehow but
I have my doubts now it's getting this
she gets us check in with Queen t6 2697
26 97's just winning maybe that's
something else Quincy 7aa Quincy 7 is
also very strong time morning
no okay blah resigns that was that was
just too bad this position it was too
bad simply jam ok this is I don't know
it's that so bad yeah it's not great but
ok night g6 it's not a good idea and h4
i think is pretty strong white is better
anyway yeah because space to bishops and
so on but this is not not good at all
after this and he's threatening h5 h6 h5
is really ugly so i went with that but
that that's like the super non
developing and and g45 yeah i thought
maybe i can just shut the whole thing
down form for a while it's an unplayable
position ready let's see a dr with
hindsight night c eight is better that
this this might might might hold for a
while this is not as s problematic as in
the game you know because i can blockade
on d5 and d6 is not hanging and it was
much better actually here I'm just I'm
just toasted 94 is strong also this is
still quite quite well it not nice but
playable for the moment yeah I'm just
just in terrible shape d 6 cm there you
played it well also this is also a this
is not as good here I'm kind of hanging
on for a moment I'm clearly worse but
here I'm i'm just getting killed I think
I have no no way to to hold this now you
just played well and this is a very
risky opening to begin with probably
probably here I should just go back not
give up the bishops too early I mean
quite obviously why this better here but
this is not this is an offbeat opening
for a reason and it this is one of them
White has got space and it's generally
in good shape okay well thanks for
watching